Welcome to Gary's Economics
today we're going totalk about
the perfect tax which is not atax at all
the 120-year wealth time limit
okay so I want to do a video on an idea called
"The Wealth Time Limit" because I think it's
super interesting but it also explains a little
bit well I think it answers a couple of the most
common questions that we get on this channel
which are do you want to raise my taxes and
why do you want to increase taxation on the
rich and also another one which is what do
you think is the best way to tax the rich so
um a few years ago I made this website called
wealth economics and I really recommend looking
at it if you're interested in understanding
basically why is I care so much about wealth
inequality and also what wealth inequality
does to the economy from the perspective of
ordinary families and ordinary people's lives
and a lot of people ask me when I put
that website up 'well how do we fix it?' and
you know I had the long think about what would
be the best way to fix wealth inequality and
I came up with this idea called 'The Wealth Time
Limit' and the idea behind the wealth time limit is
you can make as much wealth as you want you
don't pay tax on it you can give it to your
kids you can give it to your grandkids
but once you hit your 120th birthday
wealth is gone basically so when you give it
to your kids it's in a trust which has your
120th birthday on it because your grandkids
has your 120th birthday on it which means
basically you can give as much wealth as you
want to your kids your grandkids even your
great grandkids but it has to be spent by your
120th birthday now what is nice about this is
that it's a zero tax solution right there's no
tax there it's a time limit so say you inherit
10 million pounds from your granddad um and
your granddad was 80 years old you know you've
got 40 years to spend that 10 million pounds and
since you know exactly the time limit you'll make
sure that you spend all that money before the
time limit so what is interesting about this is
a zero tax solution simply a time limit nobody
is getting taxed here but what does happen is very
very wealthy people they know that they have
a fixed amount of time with which they need to
spend all of the wealth that they've accumulated
and just to make it clear they can't just spend
the money buying houses if you buy a house it
stays in a trust or buying stocks such as it
stays in the trust you basically if you inherit
huge amounts of money you are forced to spend that
money over time and what that means is very very
wealthy families will have to enormously increase
their spending so if you consider us you know
a family that is worth you know a billion quid
you know like Rishi Sunak's family you know
Rishi Sunak is I guess he's sort of 45 or something
they would have 75 years to spend a billion quid
and that's really difficult actually because even
over 75 years you're going to need to spend more
than 10 million pounds a year to run that down
and that's not accounting for the fact that
Rishi Sunak probably makes from that money
30 million-40 million pounds a year so
what it means is super rich families
have the massively massively increase their
spending and this would have the consequence of
massively increasing wages for working people
because you'd suddenly see a huge amount of demand
for goods and services because these rich people
would suddenly be spending huge amounts of money
what it would also do is make assets like housing
like stocks and shares suddenly much much more
affordable for working people because on the one
hand wages have gone up a lot on the other hand
rich people very rich families would know that
they can't simply sit on huge amounts of wealth
and grow it over time they have to sell that
which means that wealth is going to go back into
the economy back to working people so it would
create an economy where wages are super high where
ordinary workers can afford things like houses and
property and basically where ordinary people can get
rich off the back of work and I think this shows
that really what matters is that wealth flows
around the economy not just from ordinary families
to the rich but from the rich back to ordinary
families because at the moment we have a system
where over time I think it's becoming clearer
and clearer that the wealth of ordinary families
is becoming smaller and smaller and smaller over
time over generations and and that is passing to
the wealth of the rich and the very rich and if
that happens then it's obvious ordinary people
will get poorer and living standards will fall
but if you have a time limit it forces the rich
to send that wealth back through the economy and
it means that working people will be able to
access that wealth and get rich themselves and
um I think what this shows is that it's not really
simply a question of do you want High tax or do
you want Low tax it's a question of do you want
an economy where the rich get richer and ordinary
people get poorer or do an economy where everybody
has the opportunity to get rich if they work
um and I think what this shows is I'm not in
this because I want to raise taxes I'm in this
because I want to improve living standards
for ordinary people but I firmly believe
on the basis of what I've seen and what I've
done in my career that the only way to do that
is to create an economy where wealth flows around
rather than where wealth simply flows upwards
so um yeah that's the idea it's the wealth time
limit I think it's really interesting to see that
you can make a really thriving economy even with
the low tax economy if you force the rich to give
assets back to working people over time um this
is not at all to say that I'm opposed to any of
the policies which increase taxation of the rich
I'm super supportive of those policies because I
know that if nothing is done to get wealth flowing
from the super rich back to ordinary families
then we are going to see the economy get worse and
worse and worse over time but it's simply to show
it's not simply a question of high tax or low
tax you know you could have an economy which
is high tax on the rich and very low tax and
ordinary workers and that would be much better
than the economy now which is actually often high
tax on workers and low tax on the very rich
or you could have an economy which is you know
very low tax on the rich but forces the rich togive
that wealth back but at the moment what wehave
is very low tax on the richest, high tax onworkers
and no mechanism to get wealth flowing back
around and if that's what you have it's inevitable
that wealth will flow from ordinary people to the
rich and the economy will get worse and worse so
um yeah there were time limit is a nice idea it's
just an idea for you to think about to realisethat
what really matters is not so much the level
of tax but really the balance of power in the
economy and the direction of travel at the moment
we have an economy where the rich are extremely
powerful and they're getting richer & richer & richer
ordinary people are getting poorer & poorer
over time and that will obviously lead us toa bad
place but it's not inevitable there's lotsof ways
to think of... there's lots of ways to fixit & lots of
ways to think about it so somethingto think about
put a comment; let me know whatyou think
um and uh yeah I hope you found it interesting
*i have a question... if we use this time limit...
it sounds like a good idea for the long term*
*but in the short term...
would it really change anything?
wellit would!
if it was actually implemented well
because if you for the very... if you're avery
rich family you know if you are 50 years old
and you're a billionaire you know70 years
is not a long time to spend abillion quid
so the very rich families wouldhave to start
spending straight away from now because
they know that you know we haveto we
have to we have to spend that money
we can't we can't keep it forever so it would
create an enormous immediate economic stimulus
*part of the problem you've described already... but
wouldn't they just spend it on our mum's house?*
well this is the thing if you the idea is anything you
buywith the money in the trust stays in the trust
so if you use the money to buy somebody's house
it doesn't solve your problem right because you
need to anything you still have in there when
you hit 120 is gone so it it doesn't make any
sense whether it's to use that to buy assets
because they can't keep them the idea is basically
you have to sell those assets back into theeconomy
you have to keep those assets moving around
*that makes sense, I can't think of any other questions*
it's all right, it's no problem, great idea, also check out
www.wealtheconomics.org if people are interested
it'sthis good website it's went up a long time ago
it's really nice; nicely explains the ideas
housing could be so much more affordable wages
could be so much higher and we could have so
many more options in how we live our lives some
of them put a lot of money into paying Economist
and think thanks to tell you that inequality
is important for the economy that is not true